Andalucía está cubierta por más de un
millón y medio de hectáreas de Olivares
un paisaje que podría verse
profundamente transformado por la
creación de enormes parques
fotovoltaicos una transformación brutal
que amenaza a cientos de agricultores
como José blanque quien explotaba 70
hectáreas en la región de granada la
compró mi bisabuelo hace ya cinco
generaciones hace más de un siglo y que
luego pues la han ido heredando sus
hijos sus nietos estos Olivos
concretamente pues se han puesto con
todo el cariño ya están en plena
producción y se van a ver expropiados el
responsable de esta expropiación es una
empresa privada española llamada capital
Energy su proyecto fue reconocido de
utilidad pública por el estado medida
que les permite adquirir terrenos
agrícolas pagando únicamente su valor
catastral para mantener viva la
esperanza José se reúne regularmente con
dos amigos agricultores que también se
enfrentan a la expro piación
Buenas tardes chavales tenemos Alguna
novedad con el boletín oficial del
Estado decían que de palabra que lo iban
a corregir que iban a corregir pero nada
Aquí estamos y 106 107 José Sánchez y
este maricarmen Estas son las tuyas
la suma que capital Energy tendría que
pagarle a José Sánchez por la
expropiación es Casi cinco veces menor
que los ingresos anuales que produce su
explotación de utilidad pública tiene
muy poco
es una utilidad privada más bien ellos
son los que van a embolsarse
ese dinero más que engañado me siento
robado
la construcción de este megaparque de
casi 400 hectáreas conllevaría a la
expropiación de más de 150 parcelas en
caniles el pueblo se ha convertido en un
bastión de protestas su alcaldesa María
del Pilar ha estado luchando desde que
se anunció el proyecto cuando sale
publicado y yo veo 96 millones de euros
digo qué inversión más importante para
mi municipio Ahora cuando hemos leído la
forma y la expropiación es cuando hemos
tenido Claro que este proyecto no tenía
cabida en nuestro municipio
la suma propuesta por la empresa para
estas expropiaciones Es irrisoria según
la alcaldesa el ayuntamiento se supone
que recibiría en torno a un millón un
millón y medio de euros en impuestos que
realmente para un ayuntamiento como
caniles Tampoco es tanto porque no deja
de ser como dos subvenciones dos peceras
para el arreglo de dos calles es algo
circunstancial y momentáneo el pulso
entre la alcaldía y capital Energy
continúa la empresa se negó a
concedernos una entrevista
[Música]
en la actualidad en toda Andalucía se
están arrancando Olivos para ser
sustituidos por paneles solares según
las asociaciones cada año 20.000
hectáreas de tierras de cultivo son
arrasadas
hoy se reunieron cerca de Córdoba un
centenar de habitantes de la región
vinieron a denunciar la escala
gigantesca de un proyecto de parque
fotovoltaico que pronto podría ver la
luz todo lo que vemos aquí a nuestra
nuestra vista son más de 600 hectáreas
de tierra y se convertirán en placas
solares son más de 800 campos de fútbol
la amiga granja fotovoltaica que podría
construirse Aquí está dividida en cuatro
proyectos
tres de ellos le pertenecen en realidad
a una misma empresa una práctica
habitual que este ecologista vino a
denunciar
hacer la trampa de partir esa
megaplantas en otras más pequeñas pero
que al final son siguen siendo mega
plantas no entonces
la poca legislación y mala que hay lo
que hacen es manipularlo en España por
debajo de cierta capacidad eléctrica los
proyectos solares son aprobados por cada
región y no por el estado
supone un problema para las asociaciones
que consideran que Andalucía es
demasiado laxa Así que nos dirigimos a
Sevilla donde el gobierno regional
trabaja actualmente en más de 1000
proyectos para este consejero energético
el futuro de la región pasará
inevitablemente por el desarrollo de
parques fotovoltaicos la gente se tuvo
que acostumbrar a las carreteras al
trazado de tendido eléctrico a una línea
de tren nosotros tenemos también que
aprender un poco acostumbrarnos no digo
en general las cosas se están haciendo
muy bien pero siempre es posible el
error y por eso estamos también
trabajando
el objetivo de Andalucía en los próximos
tres años es convertirse en la primera
productora de Electricidad verde de
España un plan que aún le preocupa al
mundo rural